i actually don't mind living in a man's
world
i don't mind it
was
likely invented by a man
this beautiful architecture in london
was built by a man
and so i'm looking at modernity looking
at the unhappiness in women
how lost people are and how just
miserable and lifeless everyone is and
i'm like i don't want anything to do
with this i
i want to find a husband and i want to
like fulfill my husband and and have
kids
i can absolutely understand why you're
scared of this kind of stuff because
this is something bothers me as well
about the fact that i am a bit older
and it does and you have a child as well
and i have a child so number one i don't
feel the pressure of being i'm thirsty i
don't feel the pressure of needing to
find a husband because my time is
ticking or whatever it is i've already
got my child if i find my forever man
and i would love to have a family with
him but i feel like i'm in a slightly
different category um i'm not alone
obviously lots of people are like that
are you single yeah i'm single um so but
i i get why you were saying about people
being scared of being lonely and i
understand how it's not that for you i'm
not putting words in your mouth but you
were saying about um the modern woman
and the things that you see now and how
it's a man's world and everything i
understand how that could be quite scary
and you don't want that you want you
want to be happy i just want to be happy
that's what i want to be like whether or
not you know what you know it is like
like what she's saying is
the opinion and thoughts of an actual
submissive traditional woman but the
reason why most women are unhappy is
because of the ideology that they've put
in their heads and because the
ideologies you're shaping you're shaping
your reality and the society in a
different way like in her way she seems
like she's happy anyway she's all calm
but like let's say for example for you
you're looking at uh things differently
you're looking at oh if i'm a man's
doing this i feel like i have to do this
i feel like i have to do that but for
her she feels like i have to do it
because i'm a submissive woman that's a
traditional woman so you know so the
thing is about the thing is um your
dynamic you say you're 30 and you've got
a child right
so
that dynamic generally
because i speak to men a lot and a lot
of men say they don't want to get into a
relationship with a single mother yeah
that's fine i'm saying i feel like when
i meet the right person
it's not going to matter right okay i
hear that but what i'm saying is that
they're done no no no no i should be
wait i've i've heard a lot of single
mothers
speak
as if they are
the prize right
so
and they would say oh just because i've
got like i come as a package dealer
i'm not i'm not saying you i'm not
saying right i'm not saying you so
they're like i'm a package deal you have
to you know take me and my child and i'm
saying a lot of the time when women
speak like that they don't understand
how men think because
generally men if they're going to take
on your child that they understand are
taken on someone else's child it's not
their child you know i mean they're
they are the biggest man to do that as
well because i did it i know because i
did it do you know what i mean i did it
for 10 years i took on someone else's
child i was a woman for 10 years right
so i took on a woman's child for 10
years that wasn't mine we had a child
ourselves but i took on her child before
i took on mine right and one of the
things is that i understand as a man is
that
when a man takes on another man's child
that step farther role
is not ideal for any man
do you know what i'm saying so i i
always say single and the thing is
single mothers don't like to hear it
but i tell single mothers
you are very lucky to find a man that's
going to take on you and your own and i
think that's fair enough and i don't
think people should get defensive at
that yeah i really don't i think it's
just you just own your situation
i've never introduced um
my child to a man i've never been like
when i'm trying to raise a man i'm not
trying to raise a boy oh he's a boy no
no no i'm saying like for my son when
he's out yeah i'm saying if you've got
have you got you've got a boy okay it's
very important that he sees a very happy
healthy home
i don't want to be like oh this is
mommy's new boyfriend right he's never
seen me with an with a man because the
only time that he will is when i found a
man that is i i know that's my forever
man obviously things go wrong but you
know yeah you said that man needs to
love my son more than he loves me why
wait wait wait wait wait
okay
i want to say something i want to say
something on this you see the problem
the problem with single mothers is they
expect a man to come and
basically you do your thing with another
guy unconditionally the baby daddy's
still in the in this in the in the scene
you expect another man to come and play
another person's story mode because
that's basically what he's doing and
come on what love brother if if i'm if
me and you are in a relationship i'm in
a relationship with you
no offense that's that's a different
thing because let's keep it 100. i mean
when you introdu by the time that i
introduce him to my son this could take
if the guy wants to be introduced to the
sun that's coming so let me just let me
try it
let me try and give you
let me try and give you this as a man
who's actually done it and done it for
like a decade right i'm not doing it
anymore but i've done it for a decade
when you say things like he he needs to
love my child more than he loves you
let me just tell you that's not going to
happen
okay but not even at the point let me
just tell you my son men do not love
children that are not theirs
biologically
more than the woman that they're in love
with it doesn't happen why okay so i'm
i'm i'm just trying to give you some
game if you if you take it you take it
if you don't know biologically though
what about where that goes to everything
without adopting children and everything
what happens in nature when when there's
a cubs and
and even historically when they would
take over the when they would take over
a tribe
they would take the women and kill the
children yes
and and so many lions do it men are
programmed to be disgusted by other
men's kids
like they can't undo that they
understand it with that but obviously
the thing is the reason why i'm saying
this is because
you seem like a nice woman good woman
you know i mean i'm not i don't know
your life but i'm saying if you are
looking for a man
that mentality saying he needs to love
my child more than loves me
take take that out yeah seriously
okay so maybe not as clear-cut as that
but you understand the way that i'm
going no but one thing you need to
understand no because a man is going to
love you he's going to love you but
you're trying to say that if you want to
love me you need to love the whole
package and you know that i think what
she's trying to say is through your love
for me you will have love for my child
nobody having love for somebody doesn't
mean like you love them more than so for
example the time being that you're with
me in our relationship is going i
actually it for us to work because it's
not only the man that makes the choice
for us do you have children i don't but
i understand what you're saying because
i come from a home where there's a lot
of like different uh there's uh some of
my aunts have got children with
different men so it's it come with i
come from a bit of a traumatized sort of
background civil war and so on so these
things happen right and it's more like
through your love for me
yeah because you love me you will have
love for my child meaning that whilst
you're in the picture you can fulfill
the image that the role of being a male
figure but you will never be the dad and
that is why you could never love the
child
also i had the um experience as well as
my mom's uh child i was i'm the only i'm
the oldest
um i'm the only child from my mom and
dad and then my mom got married to
someone else right anyway
he was very abusive to me and my mom he
wasn't
um i don't think that
obviously it wasn't okay at all but my
mom was just taking everything that you
know he was doing because she was
pregnant at that time as well and um
yeah like i know where you're coming
from when it comes to um
what's it called what did you say again
about loving your child yeah like
i've never experienced that i've never
experienced that from my mom's
ex-husband he was just very abusive to
me and my mom what about your father my
father is he's lovely he's never done
anything he's never beaten me up he's
never done it
have you guys watched this video of this
guy that uh gives his um his son
mcdonald's his son mcdonald's yeah but
then other kids yeah that's that's
that's how it you're basically trying to
say yeah let's say for example out yavu
of a kid and he done that you're
basically he should provide for your
other kids even though you may be in a
payroll with your baby daddies or
whatever he should provide and show
equal love for let's say you have a kid
you should show equal love for your son
than his son can i tell you something so
let's go back so i want to go back to
your situation one second one time i
want to go with your situation so
your child does they do they have their
father in their life no he doesn't
and that's probably one of the reasons
why you said that and the reason yeah
the so the situation obviously i don't
want to talk too much because this is
there yeah i get you i get yeah
but um there's no bad
anything between right our situation but
because your son doesn't have his actual
father in his life
when you said oh he needs to love my
child modern loves me i'm just saying
for me the ideal and every child
every child wants to know who their
biological parent is do what i'm saying
and they want a relationship with a
biological parent do not expect any man
to come into your life who loves you he
could love the ground that you walk on
right doesn't necessarily mean he's
going to love your child the same way
it's probably not going to happen i'm
just i'm just letting you know what the
matter is i appreciate your opinion yeah
like you're saying you know how i asked
you before but we didn't touch on it
like what about like adoption you know
what i mean i don't want to talk about
that in such i'm just saying you said
biologically no man is ever so what does
that mean for children that grow and
care and go to foster yeah i mean
adoption like is that is it that the
same thing you're a mother yourself
yeah so you know what it felt like to
hold that child in your womb right for
all
that that's an experience that i as a
man i could never actually understand
because it never happened but you know
what that's like and you
do you think you can love another child
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible